artist Nino built this sculpture for The
Burning Man Music and Arts Festival the
large fish jotting out in the usually
dry and Dusty Black Rock Desert of
Nevada but he didn't expect this
days of unusually heavy rain turned the
festival to mud and left this fish
looking more at home we can really leave
or go anywhere the roads are clay the
decision to bring a fish to the desert
is to create more climate change
awareness as you see is a fish coming
out of the ground perhaps looking for
more water the second meaning
is the goddess of fresh water to the
indigenous Taino Indians from my island
of Puerto Rico the fish wouldn't take
long to find water
storm did create hazardous conditions
leading to organizers to block access to
and from the site requesting tens of
thousands of people to stay put and
conserve food and water this is the best
burn ever seriously like this has given
us the opportunity to rise to radical
self-reliance and to support each other
in the community and I'm having the best
time
[Music]
the festival is supposed to be a
celebration of music and art and
imagining a different Society with no
cash or sell signal culminating in the
burning of a wooden man
amid patchy mobile signal burners as the
festival girls are known took to social
media
all these couches are soaking wet
there's a tremendous amount of water
buildup also
but the rain hasn't dampened Spirits
that's actually part of like what this
community thrives about is to share and
create more community and others made
the most of it
Laura Khan Al Jazeera
make sure to subscribe to our channel to
get the latest news from Al Jazeera